promis das bayerische promis hautnah
heute zu besuch bei den beutel burgen
wie leben sie was denken sie was sind
ihre geheimnisse erfahren sie es jetzt
exklusiv bei promis zusammen hallo ich
bin ich noch sehr aufgewühlt war jetzt
habe ich gerade vom frühstück sehr laut
gitarre gespielt das stimmt wirklich war
da aber da musst du dich nicht schämen
es ist nun mal dein naturell ja das
stimmt obwohl mir so mega stars der
volksmusik sind bin ich trotzdem im
grunde meines herzens ein eisenharter
rocker ein ganz ein wilder bist du sowie
der peter kraus oder der ted herold ja
also wie die mireille mathieu und die
war besonders wild da haben wir doch
damals dieses lied gemacht das ist rock
340 wohl dem mal abgesehen mit langem
haar und schafften breiten lieber bleibe
ich doch daheim und lasse meine
glockenläuten ach ja das lied hat die
mama sehr gemacht da war sie begeistert
ja doch mal durch dieses foto macht die
mama die mama ein lied singen für die
mama spinnst du bist du deppert bitte
nicht so harte worte zunge das mag ich
gar nicht da mische sichern
das brauchst du zu mir ne zum kreis
hosenscheißer ich hatte damit der
kohlenstoffgehalt ist der schalker immer
wieder kurz anbieter guten wenn du
glaubst de ski nicht mehr
dann schau hin auf mein mädel dann
fliegt von proben und fünften stock ein
klavier auf den schädel
wunderschön diese macht das auch
gewitter
[Applaus]
wenn sie jetzt zu mir wieder die butter
beweist mag es gar nicht fassen schon
wieder butterbrot ist